Hey everyone, you know last week Hugh Jackman lovingly asked the
academy to not vote for our song Good afternoon in
the best song category and uh well I'm not going
to uh I'm not going to stoop to that level I'm
going to rise to the uh rise to the occasion and
rise above it all and I'm going to say right now
that I loved Hughes performance in the sun um
there's zero sarcasm here no wink wink nudge
nudge but Hughes performance as a son struggling
with his relationship with his dad and his father
it's literally one of the best of his entire
career and his career is very impressive already
so he's already nominated for a Golden Globe so
I humbly submit Hugh for your consideration okay
The Wolverine and Deadpool who's he kitten not
in your life chappy welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this will be my new Deadpool 3 video for
the Ryan Reynolds reaction video obviously teasing
the movie just a little bit and the actual title
of the movie so we'll break it all down because
they've both been posting a couple videos clowning
on each other just making it seem like they're
just regular reaction videos when really they're
actually trying to promote the movie they're
doing that thing where they just make fun of
each other but also promote the movie at the
same time if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos because
they'll be posting videos like this all year
long just to promote the movie outside of just
like the regular trailers that they released for
the film but this is Ryan Reynolds posting his
reaction to Hugh Jackman's video a couple weeks
ago making fun of him asking the academy not to
nominate his song from the spirited movie that he
just released during Christmas like his Christmas
movie with Will Ferrell for an award because
outside of his acting and playing Wolverine
and all the Marvel movies Hugh Jackman is most
known for his Broadway is performing singing and
dancing so he's really really good at seeing and
dancing in Ryan Reynolds just started doing that
in the spirited movie like it was his first time
doing a song and dance number Oh that's oh he's
dead yeah he's definitely no no he's fine he's
good well I'm not a burial anyway Ryan Reynolds
getting a nomination in the best song category
would make the next year of my life insufferable
it would I mean I have to spend a year with
him shooting Wolverine and Deadpool and yeah
trust me it would be impossible it'd be a problem
so but just to recap love spirited love will love
Octavia love the song Good afternoon love benj
and Justin but please please from the bottom of
my heart do not validate Ryan Reynolds in this way
please so Hugh Jackman was just kind of clowning
on him for being a really crappy song and dance
man and Ryan Reynolds Just jokingly posted this
video as a reaction to that trying to High Road
him making him seem like a butthole for clowning
on him for being a bad singer and you Jackman not
wanting to put up with Ryan Reynolds celebrating
his nomination like throwing it in his face all
year long while they were filming Deadpool 3
together which at the time when you Jackman
posted his video clowning on him he referred
to the movie as Wolverine and Deadpool so a lot
of people thought that that might be the title
of the film I mean I have to spend a year with
him shooting Wolverine and Deadpool Wolverine
kitten not in your life chappy in the sly teaser
at the end of Ryan Reynolds video here where he
pretends like he accidentally left the camera on
and revealed how pissed off he was throwing shade
of the title not on your life chappie also calling
it Wolverine and Deadpool the reason why he calls
Hugh Jackman chappie if you forgot Hugh Jackman
was in the chappie movie with Sigourney Weaver
it was something else he had quite the haircut
in that he was also using his real Australian
accent let's just say the chappie movie did not
perform as good as some of his other films so
Ryan Reynolds was just making fun of him under
his breath a little calling out one of his worst
movies they do that to each other all the time
like they make fun of each other's other movies
non-marvel movies all the time but because both
of them referred to the movie as Wolverine and
Deadpool that does make you wonder if that is the
official title of Deadpool 3 or if Ryan Reynolds
reaction post means that they're actually going
to call it Deadpool and Wolverine like there's no
way he's going to let them call it Wolverine and
Deadpool like no way Wolverine gets to put his
name first in the title what they'll probably
do to confirm the actual titles they'll reveal
some kind of teaser poster with a logo card like
they did in the first teaser trailer they released
this one with Wolverine's claws slashing through
Deadpool symbol as a way of teasing the actual
plot of the movie and the actual title itself
here's how they are explaining Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in the movie as well as pulling off a
bunch of the fox Marvel movie cameos with older
actors coming back to play their characters again
like OG Fantastic Four actors more Classic X-Men
actors coming back the movie is meant to be a
direct continuation of the events of Deadpool
2 where Deadpool ended the movie taking Cable's
time travel device visiting several points in his
timeline as well as other timelines changing the
past like killing a variant from his own timeline
the original weird looking version of Deadpool and
Wolverine Origins he killed a version of himself
in another timeline before he made the Green
Lantern movie he messed with Baby Hitler and
they're just gonna say that he continued messing
with timelines in the fox Marvel Universe until
eventually he tries to save a younger Wolverine
from dying earlier in his timeline like before
the events of the Logan movie but one day your
old palway is going to ask you to get back in
the saddle again and when he does say yes and
that's how Hugh Jackman's Wolverine becomes
part of the plot when they first meet they fight
like Deadpool versus Wolverine or Wolverine versus
Deadpool however you think about it Hugh Jackman's
been revealing the plot just joking about how his
Wolverine can't stand Deadpool as you would expect
they talked about this in their big teaser video
last year but part of the joke of the characters
like The Comedy of a Deadpool movie with Wolverine
is that both of them have crazy healing factors
so they would just be able to lay into each other
chopping every bit of their bodies off and healing
it almost instantly so the fight would just go on
forever eventually the TVA detects all the changes
that Deadpool is making to the timelines he's
causing so much Havoc destroying the timelines the
TVA Mobius Miss minutes come after him and that's
how they get involved in the plot that's how they
explain this is a Marvel movie because those are
core Marvel characters now in the MCU I don't know
if Tom hiddleston's Loki will also have a cameo in
the movie because they're supposed to have so many
different cameos in the movie but while Deadpool
is jumping around in his timelines that's how
they feature a lot of the cameos from the old Fox
Marvel movies like they're supposed to have cameos
from the original Fantastic Four movies I don't
know which characters are supposed to come back
right now there have been rumors about Chris Evans
coming back as his Johnny Storm he said previously
he would love to do that it's only coming back as
Captain America that he's kind of reticent about
they were gonna have Fantastic Four cameos in
Deadpool 2 but it was the original version
of the movie back when Tim Miller was still
directing it and it would have been the Fantastic
Four characters from the newer reboot version and
when Hugh Jackman says they're not touching the
events of the Logan movie because they're jumping
around timelines what he's implying is they're
just gonna say that the events of the Logan movie
took place in a distant future of an alternate
timeline and they'll be saying that Deadpool is
jumping around in a timeline that's just specific
to the fox Marvel Universe with a bunch of subtle
variations in minor timelines within it so that's
how they explain the original Deadpool here in
the newer Deadpool the Old Man Logan Wolverine
are all from the same Fox Marvel Universe but
within that they come from different timelines but
that's why I've been making jokes about Deadpool
kills the fox Marvel Universe because Kevin feige
recasting a lot of the X-Men the Fantastic Four
characters inside the MCU so what better
way to give the fox Marvel movies a big
send-off and honor them and make fun of them
a lot canonizing them through the Multiverse
just like they did with Toby Maguire's Spider-Man
movies Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man movies
and Spider-Man no way home and then proceed to do
a version of Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but just have him destroy or mess with the fox
Marvel Universe I've done a couple videos about
how Deadpool 3 is going to be a huge Crossover
with the Loki series because the TVA Mobius and
Miss minutes are going to be big characters in
the movie really hoping Deadpool helps Mobius get
that jet ski the funny joke about everybody
doing these song and dance numbers musical
performances is that Hugh Jackman actually did
Wolverine the musical several years ago when he
was promoting the Les Mis movie because it uses
the theme from Les Mis who am I I'm Wolverine
and talk about super deep Cuts one of the first
jobs I ever had working on YouTube years ago
was for a channel called Barely Political which
they rebranded the Key of Awesome several years
ago way back around 2008 2009 when I was working
for them on their video shoots we did a wolverine
musical parody with Mark Douglas here who's in
charge of the channel because one of their big
claims to fame was the Key of Awesome parodies
series and he was the lead of all those series
they went on a long-term Hiatus a couple years
ago but the funny thing is is that we did that
Wolverine musical parody years before Hugh Jackman
did his version I'll chop apart that redwood tree
and slice the Wings off of I'm not a circus freak
I'm Wolverine this is Erik Beck from Indie Mogul
with Mark Douglas there because at the time this
video was made we were part of a company called
next new networks that eventually got bought out
by YouTube so everybody went to work for YouTube
the actual company but at the time we had a bunch
of different channels making these kinds of videos
all the time and it was just a real fun way to get
into YouTube production behind the camera I only
appeared on camera in a couple of the videos on
different channels because I wasn't trained as an
actor so like it was my very first time actually
being on camera but if you've been subscribed to
my channel since I started it way back in like
2012 2013 I've talked about this a couple times
maybe you actually saw some of those original
videos back in 2008 2009 or just remember watching
them when they originally posted the late 2000s
was just like a really cool period in Real World
YouTube history because so much was going on in my
own history working on YouTube doing various jobs
before I actually started my own channel everyone
let me know in the comments though do you want
them to call Deadpool 3 Wolverine and Deadpool
or do you think the title is just Deadpool and
Wolverine they'll be posting videos like this all
year long so of course I'll do more Deadpool 3
videos soon everyone click here for my Ant-Man and
the Wasp Quantumania trailer video in Easter eggs
and click here to learn how the 10 rings of power
from the shangshi movie are connected to Kang the
Conqueror thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys in the next one!